[موسيقى]
بدايه كانت منذ اربعين عاما وانا باجمع من
القطع التراثيه
والحمد لله اتكونت عندي ما يقارب اكثر من
100 الف قطعه تراثيه تحت سقف واحد
وحاولت اني البي رغبات جميع الزوار لانه
في من يبحث عن العملات فيمن يبحث عن
الجرائد في من يبحث عن المجلات في من يبحث
عن الوثائق والمخطوطات فيمن يبحث عن
الحرفيات الحجازيه فيمن يبحث عن الاوان
الحجازيه الجلسه الحجازيه
الاجهزه المرئيه الاجهزه السمعيه اجهزه
الاتصال
والحمد لله من فضل الله جمعت هذه القطع
بعد معاناه طبعا كبيره من جميع انحاء
المملكه ومن خارج المملكه
حتى اصبح عندي هذا الكم من التراث او من
القطع التراثيه
وقد تم افتتاح المتحف في الربع الرابع من
2019 ميلادي على شرف سعاده المهندس محمد
القويحص امين العاصمه المقدسه حين ذاك
والحمد لله اصبح
المتحف
يزور العديد من الزوار
المعتمرين والحجيج واهل البلد ومن داخل
المملكه ايضا ومن خارجها
البدايه في حب واقتناء التراث طبعا كانت
البدايه من مرحله الابتدائيه كنا ننزل عند
الدكان
ونجد ساع البريد بيجيب الرسائل للمدرسين
فكانت تيجي الرسائل وعليها الطوابع فتشكل
للطوابع كانها لوحات رسم واعجبت فيها فكنت
استاذن راعي الدكان انه يستاذن من اصحاب
الرسائل باعطائي الطابع عشان اجمع الطوابع
فيما بعد لما انشات جمعيه هواه الطوابع
اصبحت عضو في جمعيه هواه الطوابع وسرت
اجمع الطوابع اللي هي البنت اللي هي غير
مستخدمه عند ما وصلت للمرحله الثانويه
طبعا كان الوالد الله يرحمه يسافر بحكم
الطوافه لجلب الاكبر عدد من الحجيج في
فتره الحج ف ترجع من السفر وتكون فيه
بقايا عملات فكان بيجمعها سواء كان عملات
معدنيه او ورقيه ومن ضمنها في بعض العملات
السعوديه
فاتكونت عنده العملات وشجعني اني ابدا
برضو ايضا في تجميع العملات وبدات جمع
العملات عندما وصلت للمرحله الجامعيه في
اولى جامعه في جامعه الملك عبد العزيز
وبحكم قرب المزادات في مدينه جده للجامعه
فكنت الجا
للمزادات او اتجه للمزادات بشكل دوري كل
نهايه الاسبوع وكنت وجدت انه حقيقه القطع
التراثيه كمان اجمل من العملات والطوابع
فحاولت اني ابدا في جمع القطعه التراثيه
وحاولت اتعلم من زيارتي للمتاحف الخاصه
اللي كانت داخل المملكه او خارجها على على
كميه القطعه التراثيه الجميله
وتاريخها والتي تعكس التراث الاباء
والاجداد وحاولت اجمع فيها لغايه ما الحمد
لله اصبح عندي ما يقارب اكثر من 100 الف
قطعه تراثيه طبعا يعني القطعه التراثيه
والمتحفيه
هذه اعتبرها انا جزء من حياتي
ويعني عشقها كاني بعشق اولادي
فانا يعني
مستحيل انه الانسان
اللي يحب ويعشق التراث انه يعني يفكر في
يوم من الايام انه يفرط فيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات